Jimmy Fallon is a better talk show host
than Jimmy Kimmel obviously obviously
all day long Jimmy Kimmel
sorry
wow come on I got a fight for Kimmel
here gross wow I think there's a little
bit of bitterness right what is it about
Fallon that you love
well you know it's kind of like the uh
the enemy of my enemy is my friend yes
you know yeah of course
um but yeah Jimmy's incredibly Fallon is
incredibly talented it's a fight for
Kimmel though because he used to be my
neighbor my opinion of him slightly
softened when I heard that he was paying
his entire staff through the writer's
strike out of his house so nice so I
I just hate him so much
I'll go like that okay fine I like that